[Music]
be quick and explosive
you want to get the jump which one of
you buttholes
is next okay danny takes eight pounds of
pressure to break your humors
we need a ringer
oh danny i'm sorry i punched you in the
breast no it felt really cool
come with me on the road i'm wrestling
isn't gonna solve my problems anymore
i'd like to have my scone that comes
free with my order
okay okay have a great day
i think you really need this
[Music]
look who the cat dragged in randy see at
the table ladies well has this been
wiped down recently she's got this
i'm gonna have you fill in for me at the
nationals
that's insane it's 15 000 insane but
first we train she doesn't
have to fight in here
it's like a little fit just let her get
it out what pisses you
off
[Music]
yeah you don't practice being a loser go
come on
[Music]
we may just be in the presence of a
golden arm
weak ineffectual oh but she has got one
damn powerful arm i'm scared yet
this is my fear i
am a golden iron
you can't go out there with your balls
out you gotta get out there with your
lames out
you